على كل من بغداد تنضم الينا مراسله صباح
العربيه زينب المشاط وتحديدا من سوق
الخضار في طرابلس مراسله صباح العربيه
رينادويه يسعد صباحكما رينا وزينب ابدا
معك زينب من بغداد ماذا عن ازمه البصل
هناك حدثينا اكثر عن الازمه بالتفصيل
صباح الخير طبعا احنا اليوم نتواجد في
يعني اكبر سوق للخضار في العراق اللي هو
يسمى بعلوه جميله هذه السوق هو الذي يعني
يورد لتجار الخضار يعني
الخضار هنا تحديدا يباع البصل بواحد دولار
امريكي يعني الكل واحد من البصل بسعر
الجمله وبعد واحد دولار امريكي فكيف تجار
الخضار يعني اصحاب محاليل البقاله يبيعوا
بي تقريبا واحد ونصف دولار امريكي وهذا
السعر يعني يفوق القدره الشرائيه
للمواطنين الطبقه المتوسطه او دون
المتوسطه خاصه وان البصل هو مكون رئيسي في
المطابخ العراقيه طبعا الازمه بدات
بالعراق مع اعلان الازمه بدات بالعراق مع
اعلان وزاره الزراعه في لبنان بايقاف
تصدير البصل الى العراق ايضا العراق معروف
بعد 2003 لانه هناك ضعف كبير المحاصيل
الزراعيه في العراق بعد 2003 خاصه البصل
ومحاصيل اخرى كثيره طبعا والعراق يعتمد في
يعني بالاستيراد المحاصيل هذه الزراعيه
وايضا ازمه ثانيه اللي هي تخلخل اسعار صرف
الدولار
هذه المنتوجات فهذا يسبب ازمه كبيره يعني
في السوق العراقيه
وزاره الزراعه قدمت حلول
احكيلنا على الحلول لوزاره الزراعه وزاره
الزراعه قدمت حلول يعني جزء
المواطن طريفه جدا
واثارت سخريه الشارع تقريبا بان وزير
الزراعه اعلن عن
حاليا يعني البصل اليابس اسعاره مرتفعه
لان هناك تحول موسمي وانتقال موسمي فهذا
امر طبيعي جدا على المواطن ان يتكيف معه
ويعني يستبدل شراء البصل اليابس بالبصل
الاخضر الذي هو
سعرا من البصل اليابس ويعتمد على شراء
البصل الاخضر فقط في هذه المرحله لحين
طبعا يعني عبور الازمه المواطنين اليوم
يعني يتعاملون مع الموضوع على مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي
بسخريه يعمل المواطن كل يوم بعض المواطنين
طبعا يعملون جرد على اسعار المواد
الغذائيه المحاصيل الزراعيه يوميا على
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
اكيد سمعنا هيك مجمل كل اللي عم بيصير
وكمان الاصوات في لبنان تعالت اليوم هذه
الاصوات انه لبنان يصدر كثيرا من البصل
الى الدول العربيه ومن بينها العراق خلينا
نروح لرينا نفهم ازمه البصل في لبنان
ريناد لما انا اروح اشتري بصل بسوق خضره
ويقولوا لك انه كي للبصل ب 75 الف ليره
واذا حكينا عن ثلاثه اكياس مع بعض بيطلعوا
ثلاث ملايين ونصف شو يعني
يعني حتى بلبنان ما عاد فينا نقول كل بصل
ونصلي حصل يعني البصل هو سلعه استهلاكيه
شعبيه دايما كانت مرتبطه بالرخص يعني نحن
مرات بنقول بيع الدنيا بقشره بصله او صام
وفطر على بصله للدليل انه هذا شيء ما كان
يحسب له المواطن اللبناني حساب اليوم
البصل بيدخل بكل اكلاتنا حتى انا يعني كنت
عند الخضار قبل كم يوم ونحنا ما بنشتغل
البصل بالكيلو بلبنان يعني مقويه قلبي وعم
بشتري قال لي مدام يعني ما تتهوري بالمزح
لانه قال لي انه في ناس ما قدرت حتى تشتري
بصل ويفضل تشتري خبز في ناس اشتريت بصله
واحده هذا كله طبعا بفرجي عمق الازمه
بلبنان ولو هي عندها ابعاد عالميه يعني
نحن كما نعلم انه ارتفاع سعر البصل مرتبط
بتراجع الانتاج باكثر دولتين مصدرتين
بالعالم اللي هم الهند وباكستان ولكن حتى
بلبنان كان عنا بعض الاضافات يعني المزارع
اللبناني زرع بصل اقل هذه السنه لانه كان
في كاسات بين الموسم السنه الماضي
وبالتالي لبنان يعني يستهلك تقريبا ينتج
تقريبا نصف حاجته من البصل وكذلك كان في
عامل رئيسي اخر هو اقدام احد التجار على
شراء كل الموجود من البصل بلبنان وتصديره
الى ليبيا هيدا خلى القفز الجنونيه سعر
البصل تتصدر مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
وتتصدر انشغالات اللبنانيين رغم كل
الازماتهم انا عجبوني كل كمان الاقوال
والامثال الشعبيه عن البصه بس حابه اعرف
اذا في بالعراق كمان هيك اقوال شعبيه او
امثال مثلا على البصل شو زينب عندكم مثل
اللي سمعتنا اياهم رينا اربعه خمسه
عندي عندي بعد يعني امثال شعبي يعني البصل
احنا احنا بس ناكله بالمطبخ هواي ههه يعني
استخدم البصله
مضبوط مثل كمان شكله في كمان اضافات خلينا
تسمعنا رينا رينا
نحن حتى البصل يعني يقال انه يلي دخل بين
البشر البصله وقشرتها او حتى مثل البصله
داخله بكل اكله هو يقالوا للمتطفلين لانه
البصل هو موجود بكل المطبخ اللبناني
وبالتالي نحن نعتمد عليه وما بنعمل له
حساب يعني بالايامات العاديه وان شاء الله
كمان
لمزيد من الامثال عن البصل شكرا جزيلا لك
رينا دوايه من طرابلس شكرا لزينب المشاط
من بغداد شكرا لكما